hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es mal wieder
einen leckeren und einfach ein klassiker
ich werde nämlich einen feuerwerk uhren
machen und zwar ist es so ein leckerer
mürbeteig mit einer spülung und
streuseln also ziemlich streuseln
obendrauf und wer dann noch möchte kann
auch eine leckere seine geschichte oben
drauf machen aber noch ein paar kalorien
wieder zu uns wird natürlich noch
leckerer ich werde euch jetzt erstmal
die zutaten für den mürbeteig zeigen und
später dann die restlichen zutaten also
ich brauche dafür 100 gramm butter 200
gramm mehl 75 gramm sahne essig zucker
75 g zucker eine prise backpulver also
geradezu eine messerspitze etwas vanille
extrakt bis aroma und eine prise salz 2
schon so arg bei der saane gebe ich
einfach alle zutaten in eine
rührschüssel geht auch nur handrührgerät
mit den knethaken und es wird dann
einfach locker zu einem teig zusammen
geknetet von der vanille brauche ich
auch nur so ein paar tropfen
wichtig ist hierbei dass die zutaten
kalt sind also diesmal nicht zimmer war
wie bei allen anderen rezepten weil der
mythos immer ganz kalt verarbeitet
werden
jetzt gehe ich noch die butter mit dazu
da geht es einfacher und schneller wenn
ihr sie bisschen klein schneidet ein
stückchen gemacht mit lass ich's einfach
vertreter kniete
so sieht der zeitplan fertig aus und ich
nehme ihn jetzt raus und stelle noch in
den kühlschrank damit eben nicht so
klebt und auch möbel wird jetzt einfach
in so einer schüssel rhein mit decken
und die schüssel braucht ihr dann auch
nicht auswaschen
denn wir brauchen sie sowieso gleich
wieder für die streusel da kann man sich
einen arbeitsgang sparen
jetzt gebe ich das kurz im kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich in der zwischenzeit schon
mal die füllung vorbereiten und für die
füllung brauche ich zwei gläser
sauerkirschen oder schattenmorellen
brauche 45 g speisestärke 1 esslöffel
zucker und ich nehme noch ein bisschen
bittermandel aroma von den kirchen
brauche ich jetzt auch ein bisschen tier
schafft aber nicht den kompletten
sondern nur 250 milliliter damit einfach
so ein schöner festa pudding entsteht
und das geht sich jetzt hier kurz ab und
fangen den saft auf
jetzt muss ich mir davon 250 milliliter
ab und den rest dann müsst ihr nicht
wegschütten
den könnt ihr dann zum beispiel einfach
mit ein bisschen wasser vermischen und
wohnungen ist ein leckerer kirschsaft
und ihr schon dass ich jetzt hier noch
business steht
gebt den saft in den topf dann gebe ich
da jetzt den zucker mit rein und
verrühren und geht auch die stärke
reihen und für die stärken
einfach schön clipping frei und dann
kommt da noch bisschen bittermandel
aroma rein passt finde ich immer ganz
gut zu kirschen dazu ein paar tropfen
jetzt kann ich auf meine herdplatte
stellen und einfach aufkochen lassen und
so entsteht dann eben der pudding
dann nämlich dem schneebesen raus und
damit einen kochlöffel geht ein bisschen
besser und gebt die kirchen dann mit
dazu ich glaube ich habe eben im kern
gesehen aber sagt einfach weiter kern
findet der den trip zu machen
oh ich hab ihn lieber raus kann halt
immer passieren
hier schossen glas sind was ich eine cd
kaputt macht berichtet noch ganz kurz
und lasse es zu 23 minuten abkühlen und
bereit in der zeit schon mal die
streusel vor
für die streusel brauche ich 110 gramm
mehl 100 gramm zucker 90 gramm butter
100 gramm mandeln gestiftet und einen
halben teelöffel zimt und hier ist es
jetzt auch ganz einfach ich gebe es
einfach alle zutaten wieder in die
schüssel rhein ist wirklich ein sehr
einfaches rezept ganz schnelles
und jetzt wird es auch einfach verknetet
die straße ist jetzt fertig sind auch
richtig schön krümelig und jetzt kann
ich bereits meine backform einfetten
ich nehme jetzt eine springform mit dem
durchmesser von 24 cm 26 gehen aber auch
28 sind vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß
dann müsste dann das rezept ein bisschen
umrechnen und jetzt fertigt es mit ein
bisschen wachstum spray auch am rand
denn am rand darf er auch nicht an
klären und dann wähle ich das jetzt noch
ein bisschen kriegen wir später nehme
ich den kuchen leichter raus wobei das
sowieso eine antihaftbeschichtung hat
aber trotzdem sicher
jetzt nehme ich den kaltenböck teig und
gebt ihm daheim
jetzt könnt ihr den einfach mit den
händen flach drücken und am rand so ein
bisschen hochziehen
und jetzt kann ich da die kirchen
bereits 1 5 und wenn der teig noch so
ein bisschen an den händen klebt ihr
habt ihr gesehen ich habe auch so ein
bisschen mehl genommen dass es nicht an
den fingern klebt dann glatt streichen
und es dann einfach schön verteilen
man könnte jetzt auch stadt der kirchen
einfach was anderes leben zum beispiel
äpfel und apfelsaft schmeckt auch
richtig gut finde ich passt aber so ein
bisserl mehr in die herbstzeit oder ihr
könnt ihn bernehmen oder jetzt wenn
frische früchte im garten wachsen könnt
ihr euch auch da bedienen und irgendwas
nehmen und einfachen passenden säfte zu
wählen als es müssten kirche sein
jetzt kommen noch die streusel obendrauf
so ein bisschen verteilen sie jetzt
ziemlich viel aus aber wenn man auch
viel kirschen drin und so leicht
andrücken
das später jetzt nicht so ab brüssel
und so kommt jetzt der kuchen backofen
und zwar stehen bereits schon vorgeheizt
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze und da
muss er jetzt ungefähr 35 bis 40 minuten
backen
man sieht es dann an den krümeln als
allen streuseln oben drauf dass die so
ein bisschen gold braun werden und
danach lassen wir ihn komplett auskühlen
ich weiß es schwierig weil er jetzt
schon lecker riecht aber da muss
wirklich komplett kalt sein und dann
kann man die sahne noch drauf geben
meinen kuchen ist abgekühlt und ich
hatte ihn auch für etwa eine stunde im
kühlschrank also da muss jetzt richtig
kalt sein denn ich geb dir jetzt gleich
noch seine drauf und dann stelle ich
jetzt mal kurz zur seite und habe jetzt
hier für die sahne also habe 200 gramm
same hab so zwei esslöffel butter zucker
einen teelöffel sonderfahrt zum seine
streifen und ein bisschen zimt und es
geht jetzt ganz schnell ganz immer
gleich fertig ich gebe jetzt das den
puderzucker zur sahne mit dazu und nehme
jetzt ein handrührgerät und schwarzes
schaf mit dem salat
und jetzt gebe ich die sahne einfach auf
den kuchen drauf werde so nicht möchte
kann auch die sahne einfach dazu reichen
aber ich finde so eine dünne schicht
obendrauf schmeckt einfach nur viel
besser aber jetzt jemand zum beispiel
keine sahne marx und der andere tochter
macht man halt lieber nebendran dann mit
auf den teller
so jetzt einfach ein bisschen
verstreichen muss jetzt auch jetzt
gleichmäßig sein als noch so schöne
wellen wenn auch schön der oberfläche
hat halt den vorteil wenn man die sahne
nur dazu reicht zum teller dann ist der
kuchen auch länger haltbar
also da kann man dann auch so zwei tage
oder drei tage sogar aufhebe und halt
die sahne einfach dazu reichen
und jetzt täter noch bislich würde
geschmack und für die optik ein bisschen
sind und jetzt ist unser kuchen bzw
unsere torte schon fertig ich weiß
übrigens nicht wieso der feuerwehr kuch
heißt also wahrscheinlich wege der rote
kirche im inneren aber ich weiß woher
das wort jetzt kommt voller kuchen an
vielleicht weiß jemand von euch ich kann
denn jetzt anschneiden demokrat gucken
immer so skeptisch an
mallory sowohl sind ich auch danke das
sieht auch richtig gut aus also unten
dieser märkte anschaue dann die saftigen
kirchen und die haben das schöne aroma
durch dieses bittermandel aroma und dann
die knusprigen streusel und die sahne
also ich glaube das ist auch so ein
perfekter kuchen des schilling darf
probieren und dein urteil aussprechen
und ich probiere dann später liebster
kuchen zu grubinger weiß also nicht
heißen ja das stimmt
beim essen verfremdete ich immer oder
ich verbrenne ich immer und sich neben
deinem schneekoppe main 27 wirklich weg
ist richtig richtig gut sagte dazu ja ob
sie das mal meiner gleichen kaffee dazu
also ich glaub ich denke heute zu meinen
lieblingskuchen weil einfach alle
komponenten
ich mag zimt und mandeln und kirschen
und ein mürbeteig und streusel und sahne
also ich glaube perfekter geht's nicht
ihr kriegt das rezept so nachlesen auf
zehn.de für mich freuen wenn die nach
macht und mir einfach ein foto auf
instagram oder facebook schickt und wir
sehen uns dann wieder beim nächsten mal
mit einem anderen klassiker ich mach mal
wieder mal klassiker finde ich immer gut
bis bald den start gehen die klassiker
hat erscheint der war zu schmecken
der schmeckt wirklich dass ich nicht
mehr
das schmeckt auch immer bei uns ok ich
glaube es dir